el destino de calle winehouse de 18 años
está ahora en manos de un jurado el
adolescente es acusado de disparar
contra tres personas y matar a dos de
ellas durante las protestas que
siguieron al tiroteo de jake blake un
hombre negro por parte de un oficial de
policía blanco el tiroteo en agosto de
2020 sirvió de combustible para impulsar
el movimiento black great smarter
winehouse se encontraba entre un grupo
armado que fue a qué noche en wisconsin
diciendo que querían proteger a las
empresas de los manifestantes los
fiscales argumentan que el joven fue
allí en busca de problemas cuando mató a
tiros a josep en razón bomba de 36 años
y antoni hoover de 26 e hirió a gateway
corts de 26 años en gestarse cannes en
apenas unos segundos el acusado mata a
una persona intenta matar a dos más y le
arranca el brazo a game cross cruz es
así de rápido es alguien que no tiene
remordimientos no tiene respeto por la
vida sólo se preocupa por sí mismo con
lakers soft
sus abogados afirman que winehouse
estaba siendo atacado y que actúa en
defensa propia
kyle rittenhouse le disparó al señor
rosenbaum porque él lo estaba atacando
todas las personas a las que les disparó
lo atacaban
durante su testimonio el adolescente se
derrumbó en el estrado de los testigos
y tumbes
mientras los manifestantes se reúnen
frente al palacio de justicia el jurado
de 12 personas todos blancos excepto uno
de ellos está deliberando sobre su
destino
winehouse se declaró inocente y podría
enfrentar cadena perpetua si es
declarado culpable